good morning Jay good morning gentlemen
how are you
McLovin is so upset that he didn't get
into Duke and Stanford he went to dart
and he went to Dartmouth so he has this
bias against Duke and Stanford you
probably faced that before right I've
heard a few negative things about Duke I
don't know where it comes from because
we're all wonderful people or you are
humble in every way did the Ivy League
schools recruit you yeah I had several
Ivy League schools recruited me and
oddly enough an ivy school of recruiting
me got me out of taking the SAT again if
you can't believe that my mother was was
very much into me being able to get into
the College of my choice so when I
flipped the SAT the first time I think I
had gone to some kind of junior prom or
something like that and had violated
every every rule of drinking adult
beverages before I was legal and the
next morning I did not do well on the
SAT and my mom thought I couldn't get
into a good college with that score and
and I told her mom I can get in anywhere
with this this makes me locker-room
genius I'll be fine and and so she said
you can't get in an Ivy League school
and I said yes I can and and I sort of
made her a bet I said it I'll let an Ivy
League school in for a visit and and if
they say this is good enough and I don't
have to take it again and she was
convinced that it wouldn't work and so I
had an Ivy League school in for home
visit and they weren't even in the door
before I said here's what I got in the
SAT can I get in and they said yes I was
like bingo and it's like so I didn't
have to take it again it was great if
you could put in one sentence why you
think this sports community doesn't like
Duke
if I could put it in one sentence I I
think it has to do with the honestly
with the fact that that Duke has won so
much in the television era and it's it's
like you can't escape it and people have
been it happened it started down in 1986
when we went to the Final Four we had a
Prescott you know they have a press
conference at the Final Four and so you
have where all the starters are there
that ours was like a comedy show and and
all that stuff we had a really good time
so people started writing all these
articles about you know how great we
were and Louisville came up afterwards
and they were just as good and great
guys everything but they didn't is it
their thing wasn't as fun for the media
and and all the articles that were
written about how how great we were
people are people out there going wait a
minute our guys are smart too or our
guys are nice too or I guys do this too
we thought our guys help little old
ladies across the street too and and
we're boy scouts like what the hell I
understand where it comes from it's just
the ubiquity of it that you can't get
away from it and and I'm okay with it I
don't have a problem with it my favorite
compliment that I get is when people
come up to me in an airport or somewhere
it says and they say I hate Duke but I
don't hate you and I'm like wow that's
really nice thank you very much
they don't say that to Laettner they
probably do you know later is a good guy
you know right yeah I like him I just
think people look at him differently I
don't know I think it's because Duke and
good-looking and you like he won he had
big like he did everything you would
want in an athlete but I think that fact
that he embraced being a villain bothers
people a little bit that's probably true
and I mean look I'm not fooling myself
the reason the reason that that Duke
caters like me is because I saw didn't
you guard Purvis Ellison in that
national title game i guarded him i
guarded him for part of the game but the
truth is that Ellison scored most of his
points against Danny Ferry in the
galleries and there when there were
switches so it was really their fault of
course it was Jay Bilas of course
shifting the blame joining us ESPN
college basketball analyst right how do
you sum up what happened last night it
that was a head scratcher last night you
know I don't think it was that crazy
that Loyola Chicago won you know beating
a seven seed I was alone I was a little
surprised the Kansas State was able to
muster enough offense to beat Kentucky
because Kansas State doesn't score very
easily and I mean if you look at all the
metrics that that that was the head
scratcher so you've got something now
that's really it's never happened before
we've had 11 seats that have reached the
Elite Eight before and we've had 11 3 3
- final four before so it's not you know
Loyola Chicago is not a crazy thing that
happens as the crazy thing is having
tonight get all the way to the to the
Elite Eight and do it in the same year
as an 11 and now we've got two nines I
guess with Florida State you know played
I guess if you look at it historically
and say is this really know that's the
unprecedented thing sort of adding the
seeds up and you got 20 an 11 and a 9 or
the Nets go to the Final Four and I
don't know who would have said hey you
know watch out I mean this tournament
solid enough we could have Loyola
Chicago and Kansas State playing it out
for Final Four berth I don't think
anybody would it would have thought that
we have talked a lot about defense I
think more in this tournament than I
remember because you know Duke and
Syracuse with that similar two-three
zone
I thought Florida State's length gave
problems last night it just feels like
defense is playing a little bit more of
a prominent role or am I reading too
much into this no I mean I do think
we've talked about defense before and in
advancing you know Duke and Syracuse
it's it's a little bit weird because
you've got both teams playing playing
that same sort of type of zone and Dukes
never done that before except for this
year so that's a little bit that's a
little bit odd as far as the matchups
concerned but you know part of part of
the reason we're talking about defense
is because some of these teams couldn't
muster any office and I mean you know
how many free throws did the Kentucky
miss last night I mean they must of us
13 14 free throws mm-hmm and they cost
the ball up like crazy but you know the
so the transition points didn't
shock me he turned the ball over teams
are gonna get layups what what surprised
me was that Kansas State
you know whether its Savior Snead or
Cartier Giada getting guys like that
makin making so many perimeter shots
it's not like they they were you know
all of a sudden turned into those
Showtime Lakers but they they made more
than I expected and they made just
enough to win so that was but it was
surprising at the end I was really
surprised when Calipari did call a
timeout when he had the ball where they
were you know down one and had a chance
to take the lead that was a that was a
surprise yeah he said that post game
there was also a little bit of an exit
controversy but certainly there was the
attention brought to the fact that
Kentucky players and John Calipari
didn't shake hands after the Kansas
State get your thoughts on that well I
didn't I didn't even notice that so you
know usually they do that little leak
and shake where everybody lines up like
after a little league baseball game or
something which I've never been a fan of
but you know you have guys jumping
around and celebrating I don't know if
people did lineup if Kansas State did
and they got they got stiff I have no
idea so I didn't I didn't really see
that that could bother me anyway you
know it just seemed like this is this is
one one area Dan where I like the games
better now in just about every way that
it was you're fast but there's one thing
that I I'm the old man you know saying
get off my lawn and that is like it does
seem like when we were younger and
people shook hands they shook hands
because they wanted to not because they
had to light up and say two four six
eight who do we appreciate you know I
don't really get that yeah I'm with you
on that
give me the surprise tonight I don't I
don't know that I come up with anything
I mean you know tonight is or is a
little bit more bigshots you know
there's not who's playing tonight that's
a bit that's a huge surprise Syracuse
yeah but I mean Cirque uses they you
know talk about having done fo something
before they did this two years ago you
know when they made the final four is an
11 seed III or maybe as a 10 but they
were a double-digit seed yeah okay
that's that would be surprised well how
about this
Syracuse wins tonight that will be the
shocker of the tournament because
Syracuse can't score and and if they're
able to muster up 70 points I think
you're gonna have to have you could have
to have at least 65 70 points to win
this game if they can muster that up
that would be that would be the shock of
the tournament because I don't I don't
see any way they win unless you know
unless you have some sort of scenario
where Duke does not make a shot outside
of five feet which I don't see that
happening either I mean Michigan State
got like 25 offensive rebounds and still
couldn't win like they couldn't make
anything so and I don't see Duke doing
that they're a good zone offense team
and they're gonna do one thing that
Michigan State did they're gonna dribble
kind of trait that zone and they're
gonna get into gaps off the dribble and
and I think they're gonna win by double
digits but but you know we've been
surprised another tournament but that
would be a shocker for me
Bagley versus eight and pro potential
eaton looks to me like the prototype NBA
big guy because he can shoot at man
and that guy's really good Bagley still
scratching the surface he's a little bit
more of unorthodox and unconventional
but he's got he's got greater quickness
and his ability to get off the floor two
and three times and with the explosion
that he does I haven't seen I can't even
think of anybody that does it as well I
know there because there has to be
somebody but they're both impressive
early in the season I was thinking oh
geez Bagley's and I'm going pick but
after seeing eight and so much
I'd go with eight and but but Bagley
wouldn't be far behind he would be he
would be two for me his Steve Alford
safe at UCLA
I don't know I hope so but you know how
UCLA is it's a it's a weird place and
there are a lot of people who still
think that you know John Wooden could
come back kind of like Elvis you know
Elvis hasn't passed away or anything
it's but it's an odd job you know for a
long time they didn't pay so it was hard
for them to get you know get people then
when you know I was one of those that
thought that that's firing Ben Howland
wasn't the best best idea you know he
went to three straight Final Fours which
had done there sits wood and so it's
nothing to get Steve but I was saying
hey you know who do you think you're
gonna get that's gonna do a better job
with Bam and he's done a really good job
at Mississippi State I hope he's okay
but but you know how it is dan like he
like Memphis fired tubby smith after two
years there's you never know with these
jobs it's pro sports now so it doesn't
have to make sense like a like you think
it used to but you also you made the
move with tubby smith because of Penny
Hardaway being there and maybe his
pipeline to all those high school kids
in Memphis I I don't know if there's
somebody in the on-deck-circle UCLA
where they go if we get him we get this
I understood the Penny Hardaway move a
little bit more because he has all of
those great players and the number one
player you know next year in college
basketball or going into college
basketball the recruit so I that a
little bit more I'm not sure if I really
has that I don't say if they do I don't
I don't know who it is and and I get it
to about Penny Hardaway and maybe hilly
I'm sure will do a great job I mean he's
a great guy I have a I just don't
understand why Memphis didn't hire for
the first place you know he had access
to all the talent two years ago and was
coaching that same high school I know it
had only been one year but you know to
me I was more critical of the
administration and their their
decision-making for look what if you're
going to do this what easier two years
ago why would you hire tubby Smith's in
the first place it's not like you need
you need some sort of map to tell you
who the guy is
I mean it was pretty clear and so I did
I didn't think he was given a legitimate
chance and you know I'm not even worried
about whether you know he was cut off or
for talent in Memphis by Hardaway or
whatever that's business if you want to
do that do that I don't really care
about that but you know if you wanted
Hardaway you had him two years ago
there's no reason I are talking the
first player he's Jay Bilas the ESPN
college basketball analyst uh what was
the nickname we came up with Jay the
last time Paul you were calling me the
moral compass yeah that's right whew
it's okay remember the nickname how good
is
yeah my bad but you remembered it but
but I look I just dispense information
then I move on it's up to you to absorb
it consume it so I if you were tuna I
got you in the net that's a good point I
feel I feel boxed in that that's okay
that's a winner right sir Roxanne why
I'm gonna boxing on you he's the moral
compass Hunico
Thank You Jay have fun tonight
Thank You dad good to be with you but
that's Jay Bilas for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]